let's quickly get into things uh the the
governor gave his state of the state
yesterday he released his uh proposed
budget earlier this week
uh your thoughts on how his proposal is
going to
play in the legislature when the rubber
meets the road
i feel that since the party in charge is
also the party the
governor i think that they will go along
with his budget
and i think it'll sail along pretty good
and i
worry a little bit about the concept is
very optimistic that we're only going to
be two percent down on revenue
uh i think as always it doesn't matter
what anyone says at this point in time
it really comes down to that final
economic forum number
because that establishes the amount of
money that we'll have to spend
you mentioned the optimism and it seems
as though the
the governor's proposal does lean quite
a bit on federal assistance
um how much federal assistance do you
think nevada is going to get
moving forward versus how much it should
be getting
you know i have no idea what the federal
government is going to end up putting
forth as far as federal assistance i
think it'd be wiser
to not rely on federal assistance and to
create
a budget that is only accessing the
funds that we have available
and then from there if we do get federal
assistance
we use that to shore up some of the
programs or restore programs
that we were not able to do or have cut
in the past due to lack of funding
i also feel it would be wise to set some
sony aside for the rainy day fund
uh knock on wood this never happens
again but
imagine if we get a new variant of this
coronavirus or something else occurs
that further destroys our economy it
would be
very wise to put some more money away in
that rainy day fund
assemblywoman titus in her uh response
yesterday referenced a variety of things
but
one of the things that she mentioned had
to do with um
the election and trying to look at some
ways to
um i don't know if change is the right
phrasing but
she wanted to address some of the
issues that were in the last election at
the legislative level so that maybe
there aren't
questions moving forward what do you
think maybe
the legislature should take up in this
session
on that topic well on the subject of
election reform
what occurred is during the pandemic the
majority party forced through
legislation to change the rules of the
game between the primary and the general
election
now when you're a kid and somebody
decides to change the rules of a game
halfway through the game
it doesn't sit very well and in that
respect there's a lot of people out
there
on both sides that had a lot of problems
with the election
and there's a lack of feeling i think
from the populace
that it has the same integrity that it
once did and i think it's important
on behalf of legislature that both
parties come together
figure out some common sense reasonable
solutions to help restore some integrity
and part of that of course is the speed
at which the results are available
when it takes so long to count the votes
people become frustrated
and i don't care which side of the aisle
you're on i mean let's face it when the
election's over we want to know the
results
we don't want to wait a week or two
or three to get those results
so i think there's some common sense
changes that hopefully both parties can
try to reach across the aisles and agree
upon
to restore some integrity the process
when you say changes
um what kind of changes kind of broadly
would you
recommend what i remember
when the secretary of state's office and
the parties
made these changes it was sparked by the
pandemic
ideally there won't be a pandemic in the
next national election
or local election but
what could be done too
in the last legislation that passed
through it indicated that if we're under
a state of
emergency that everyone would be mailed
to ballot hopefully we're never under a
statewide emergency again for such a
long period of time
of course then again brings the question
is when are we ever going to get out of
this state of emergency
so that we can regain the ability to
function
rather than having to wait and wait
for rules from the governor that
sometimes don't make a lot of sense
in that respect we won't have that issue
hopefully in the next election
as far as everyone being mailed the
ballot the concept of mailing inactive
voters a ballot is problematic to me
and should never have been done it
should never be done again
and someone should be penalized though
there should be some repercussions to
individuals who do such horrid things as
sending vows to people that don't exist
and not only from the fact that maybe
possibly
individuals might be bad actors and
return those ballots
but also loved ones don't necessarily
like being reminded
and they get reminders every day that
their loved ones have passed
but to literally three years later get
about in their name
tends to offend them and it shouldn't
have been done
that being said i don't really care for
the ballot harvesting that was passed in
the last session that has nothing to do
with the pandemic
and goes on in perpetuity regardless i
don't think it's wise to let anybody go
around and collect up ballots
also i prefer to see some consistency in
our elections
i believe that all counties should
function the same
and the fact that one county the largest
county york county clark county allowed
a computer to verify the signatures
where everyone else used human beings
and if you look at the
disportionality between the number of
votes or rejected
by humans versus that computer i believe
that elections should be consistent
across the state of nevada
and shouldn't have so much variance
county county now some variances are
understandable
maybe different voting hours it's rather
common in clark county to have souls to
the polls
and have people vote on sunday i brought
that up one time as a bill and
it's like well we have consistency well
i learned my lesson
you don't mess with the souls to the
polls and you also don't try to make the
rules do souls to the polls
because the rule people like no sunday's
for church you don't vote on sunday
government shut down you
don't that's that's absurd so it's just
a difference so there's some minor
changes
you know county to county but on the
counting
and the signature verification no to me
there should be consistency
in the uh now president biden just
gave his his speech over in washington
dc he talked a lot about unity
here in nevada i'm wondering how much
unity you believe
there can be on just a statewide level
between people who are maybe republican
and democrat and then also in the
legislative
session how much unity do you think
there can be that achieved
when you're up there trying to get laws
passed trying to navigate the budget
trying to work on
all these important issues because i get
the sense in your voice that there's
there's frustration that still lingers
from what we've just been through
oh no in that respect democrats and
republicans
democrats are great people republicans
are great people independence green
parties
people are people they're great the
issue is sometimes that
parties choose to put certain
individuals forth in leadership
positions
that unfortunately sometimes can be
pathologically partisan
and that's the real problem we need to
do what's right for the state of nevada
and as far as the issue of what's
happened in previous sessions
yeah there's some bad blood things were
forced down the minority party
told you're just going to take it we
don't care about you
however if you look at the holistic
approach
95 of bills pass on a bipartisan way
there's very few bills that are really
pathologically partisan
that we all just say no we can't go
there we're not going to do that
and it's sad that those bills are forced
through but they're in power and they're
using their power
however that may not be the best thing
for the state demeanor i beg your pardon
um one of what are some of the main
issues
taking election reform aside what are
some of the other main issues that you
would like to address when you're
in carson city at the session um
big topics there's a lot of things to
deal with well
fundamentally we need to get the state
back up and running
education needs to be dealt with
we need the kids back in school
i know that sounds crazy but if you look
across the state we only have one county
that hasn't gone back to school
that's a problem and they're clamoring
that they need to get the shot
well teachers in northern nevada went
back to school without a shot
and so we need to figure out how to get
these kids back in a productive
environment
when the kids aren't in school it makes
it very difficult for the parents
to go to work every day so to me that's
the main focus is the education
of the children of the state of nevada
and the way to do that is to get them
back into
the classrooms now in that respect
we need to have some discussions about
getting that done you know as far as
getting the vaccine out or
you know what needs to be done we were
told last time we need this and then we
can start school
we're told that by the teachers union
okay
let's get that went to the governor
let's get this let's get this
unfortunately it wasn't done
but those things then were delivered a
month later outside of the special
session
yet school did not start again
so i think education is a huge issue as
it has always been in this state
then the other thing is i believe we
need some
guard rails on uh chapter 414 in a
battery vise statute that gives the
governor
complete power to do this type of thing
without discussion with the legislature
we need to have all branches of the
government we shouldn't have one branch
dictating everything
it should have to go through the
legislature and through the judicial
branches
in order to make sure that we have a
balanced form of government
um just quickly on education
the issue of changing the funding
formula
kind of got um hesitated a
slowed down because of the pandemic and
a variety of other things do you
envision that being
revisited and what concerns do you still
have
over changing how education is funded
and where the
how the pocket of money is dealt with
correct the obviously the formula on the
budget
and that one was not a republican versus
a democrat issue in any way shape or
form
it did end up being a little bit of
north versus south uh
rural versus world war ii i know and
that's just a reality
due to mining funds and the way the
constitution was written
funds stayed inside of a county what
were extracted from that county so if
the resources were extracted from that
county
they stayed in that account as far as
mining was concerned
and over time it was felt that the
larger counties were not necessarily
getting a proportional share based upon
the allocation per student
in that respect so a bill was brought
forward and i voted no and everybody
else voted yes
and it passed and so we're trying to
create more balance over time within
that allocation funding formula
and we'll just have to kind of play it
out do i imagine we're going to have
tweaks to it
absolutely every session we've tweaked
with the
amount of money going to education
whether it be rural whether it be
urban whether it's north versus south
doesn't matter we've always tweaked with
that formula to try to create a better
balance and we will continue to
um in my recent reporting around
southern nevada you know obviously clark
county is clark county but i've been to
esmeralda county i've been up out to nia
county amargosa valley
you know i've gotten outside of the
valley here in clark county quite a bit
and i know the pandemic and the
shutdowns and the
way it's different in las vegas than it
is
in goldfield or tonopah or perum
can you help maybe the viewers down here
in southern nevada
understand the impact of
the pause in rural communities with your
voters
especially up in northern nevada what
are do you believe are the differences
between what's how it's been
affecting up there versus down here
rural versus
urban and what do you what
what do you think should be addressed
i believe that more control should have
been given to each individual county
so that they could more custom tailor
solutions for their counties you know
you look at it and i don't care whether
it's north versus south
you have a family of six people now
you're being told if you go to dinner
you can only sit four at a table
well you rode in the car together all
the way to dinner and you're gonna go
home together
so how does this make any logical sense
and i think that's the reality is we
should have been left to individual
counties
to deal with as far as
the effect on county county you know i
don't know how
aggressive the health department's been
down in clark county i'm told it's been
fairly aggressive
counties that live close to carson city
tend to get a lot of visits from osha
in that respect whereas counties that
are a little further away don't
necessarily get as many
visitors from the government giving them
fines or edicts
on how their businesses should be run so
we have seen some differences
in that respect also different
communities
my community is douglas county has a
fairly high contingent of retired
individuals
and due to that fact that we're all a
little bit older in this community
far more people wear a mask on a common
basis where if you go to
younger areas not so much
you know and part of that's just the
reality of this disease
or rather that's the virus in that
respect it tends to affect people
that are older uh final question um just
kind of broadly when the legislative
session starts
how would you characterize it
what do you think it's going to be like
well
my opinion is that we should start like
everyone else
if businesses and society is limited to
25
we should open up the building to 25
percent
and if governor lifts that to 50 we
should do 50.
i don't believe that's going to happen
would you believe that we're going to
open up
as we did during the special sessions
which is not open
i find that problematic our state
constitution clearly dictates that that
building needs to be open during session
this concept that some of the lawyers
have come up with as long as it's
available online
that works i disagree with i don't think
that's a good form of government
and hopefully we can start to open up
that building over time as more and more
individuals get the vaccine
several legislators and several staff
members have gotten the vaccine
hopefully those numbers will
increase to the point where we can open
up where people feel comfort
and also individuals like myself i have
i recovered from covid i got it back in
november about same time frame as the
governor
and in that respect there's a few
legislators and staff
that i've also recovered from kovitz so
between those that have been vaccinated
and those individuals that have
clean villa health meaning that they
have the antibodies
you know in that respect i think that
you know there's hope
that we will not go the entire 120 day
session closed
but i'm fearful it's very hard when you
close something to open it back up
i i spoke a week or so ago with sallyman
roberts and he kind of
brought up the same concerns what what
is the
um what how what is the detriment to
having the main legislative session be
virtual as the interim sessions were and
as the special session was
you know the citizens are where we do
this job
that's our job is to look out for the
citizens of the state of nevada
and the value of having them in the
building having discussions with us
disagreeing with us sometimes making us
realize
wow we didn't we weren't thinking of
those unintended consequences from this
piece of legislation
we really should modify this or not do
it
that's the danger to me